j'ai étudié la biologie du développement
j'essaie de comprendre comment les
cellules souches arrive à former un
organe antilles plus précisément je
travaille sur la rétine qui est la fille
de membranes des neurones qui tapisse le
fond de votre aide la rétine capte les
rayons lumineux donc la lumière et la
transforme en influx nerveux qui permet
la vision par contre ces phénomènes est
pas le même dans l'enfant du règne
animal
par exemple les poissons dispose d'une
deuxième population de cellules souches
qui contribuent au développement de la
rétine
durant le stade embryonnaire mais aussi
durant la vie adulte ce qui permet à
l'oeil de grandir mais aussi de se
réparer ce qui fait que les dommages
sont pas permanents est-ce que les
mammifères ont aussi cette deuxième
population de cellules souches que d'un
demi million de canadiens ont des
problèmes de vision
y at il un potentiel thérapeutique c'est
ce qu'on a cherché à savoir
[Musique]